we are the eternals
The Avengers Thor Spider-Man but we have
Tina
I'm sure that was a lot of fun for you
it was
[Music]
[Applause]
eternals assemble great life experience
the Marvel Cinematic event
centuries in the making Jack I saw him
on TV with the cape truly laser beams
I don't wear a cape Marvel Studios
Eternal free PT 13th November 5th get
tickets now
in the beginning there was nothing
even the Infinity Stones were but the
shadow of a dream then there was the
first Sun galaxies and then a bunch of
other boring stuff and then there was
Kingdom
Eternal extraordinaire and a giant movie
star pure of heart and big of by sappy
sorry did you
say anything
okay
thank you
bestowed with powers far beyond Immortal
man Kingo protects Humanity from Evil
deviants aided in his quest by a
revolving cast of Sidekicks some of whom
ah seriously dude sidekick oh God I was
just making it my own I was like
everything you make everything your own
sorry sorry assistance is that better
okay I can see that's not good helpers
what's going on oh you're gonna love
this uh-huh I know what did you say was
come on
Angelina Jolie is not one of the
sidekicks she's one of the main ones
okay all right all right I'll start over
let me just start over Okay please
[Music]
in the beginning
if you guys could not look at me it
makes me
very just okay we'll turn around but
she's not gonna turn around yeah just
turn around thank you